hey what's up my name is samuel leeds
and in this video i'm going to be
talking about lease option agreements
now this is quite a technical video
around lease option agreements
i'm going to be talking about some of
the pitfalls and the things that you
need to really watch out for so
if you don't even know what a lease
option agreement is and you're brand new
to property investing
and creative strategies where you can
buy houses using very very little of
your own money then i would suggest that
you go and check
out the what at least option agreement
is video that i did i'll put a little
card up where you can check it out i'll
also leave that in the description
but if you understand what they are you
get the big picture of them and you're
more interested in the legalities and
the pitfalls then this video might be
for you
so there's a few pitfalls of lease
option agreements and i'm going to give
you the pitfall but then i'm also going
to give you the solution
you see some property trainers out there
they'll try and put you off doing it
because they just want all the good
deals for them so they'll tell everybody
else no no don't do it it's hard it's
wrong it's this it's that
but secretly they're succeeding or
they'll tell you it doesn't work because
it didn't work for them
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
tell you the pitfalls but i have
successfully
i'm just going to put it out there i
have successfully built up a very large
property portfolio
multi multi-million pound property
portfolio and i've successfully used
lease option agreements to help me get
there
so it does work you can buy properties
with very little money down and you can
literally with as little as one pound
transaction fee
of course solicitor fees as well you can
secure a lease option agreement
benefiting from capital appreciation
and also monthly cash flow so it's a
really good way of buying properties
without having to keep
saving up money and putting down
deposits but there are pitfalls
i'm going to give you those right now
and then i'm going to give you the
solution to the pitfall but you have to
be really careful
so firstly if you like my youtube
channel please do me a massive favor and
smash the like button
that's the first step to being
successful in properties to smash the
like button destroy it annihilate it and
also drop a nice comment as well
um just to you know give me motivation
to keep going because i don't even i
don't think there's any ads on this
channel by the way so i do this just
really to help people so drop a comment
if you're grateful for the video
subscribe turn the notification bell on
really important do it right now so
first problem is
with lease option agreements if you're
taking on somebody's house
with the view to renting it out you're
taking over their mortgage
with the view to renting it out what
happens
if the current mortgage doesn't permit
you
or isn't the correct type of mortgage to
rent the property out
let's say it's a residential mortgage so
you secure a lease option agreement and
you say hey i'll buy your house now but
i'll pay for it in seven years time
and in the meantime i'll take over the
mortgage so you take over this property
but it's on a residential mortgage so
how can you rent it out
without committing mortgage fraud that's
a pitfall
the answer to that and the solution to
that and sometimes it could scoffer a
deal
if there is a mortgage on the property
that restricts you from renting the
property out
that could scrapper the deal but the
solution is
is firstly you've got to check to see if
there are any restrictions and if there
are
you're going to have to ask the lender
or ask the owner to ask the lender
to get consent to rent the property out
now in my experience what you'll find is
i mean lease option agreements will tend
to be properties that either are in
negative equity
or they might not even have a mortgage
on them or they might be tired landlords
that have already got
the right to rent it out but if it's a
residential property
the reason that they'll be happy to sell
you the propaganda lease option
agreement is because they're in negative
equity
if they're in negative equity just bear
with me a second
that means that they bought the property
high it's dropped down low
the mortgage lender is probably feeling
pretty uncomfortable right now because
the value of their house
is lower than the mortgage that's a
problem for a lender
so most lenders will give consent
to that property to that owner for the
owner to rent it out as long as they're
getting their monthly mortgage
payments so i would just say ask the
lender for consent
tell the lender look this property is
negative equity
by the change of circumstances i want to
move out please could you give me
consent to rent the property out and
usually they will do that so that's the
solution around the problem so
get permission before you rent the
property out if
there's a restriction on the property at
all second pitfall of lease option
agreements are
and i've heard people say this they say
the types of properties
that are done on lease option agreements
tend to be very cheap properties in
shabby areas with
bad tenants rough neighborhoods that's
why
the owner is wanting to get rid of the
property in the first place
i think that's kind of a little bit of a
weak pitfall if i'm perfectly honest
because of course
when you're doing any property
transaction whether you're doing it on a
rent to rent at least purchase lease
option agreement
whether it's a hmo or buy to let
whatever it is a flip even
you're gonna have to do your due
diligence on the area and make sure that
the property is gonna be cash flowing
positive
so if it's in a cheap area that means
that probably the mortgage payments or
the monthly payments are going to be
cheap as well
so that means that the expenses are low
which means that the profit margins are
likely to be higher so
you just need to make sure you you're pr
profiting you've got a positive
monthly cash flow of at least 200
pounds per month before you take on any
property even if it's a free house
just because it's a free house doesn't
mean it's a good house
i think some of my students have done
the lease option training and then
they've been like oh my gosh i'm i'm
desperate to just go and secure
a lease option agreement now and they'll
they'll go and get a deal and they'll
sign it and they're so excited but
yes technically it's a it's like a free
house you're putting down a pound
but it's a terrible house you're going
to be losing
100 a month on it so always make sure
the property is not in a terrible area
it's going to attract terrible people
and also it's going to be cash flowing
200 pounds a month
okay next pitfall this is a real big one
and most people don't know about this
because again not be i'm not mean to
like um be disrespectful to people that
teach at least option agreements um a
lot of people go on my course do some
training
maybe at best secure one lease option
agreement and then start teaching it and
it's like no
like to teach something you have to have
done it for years
i didn't start teaching until i was
financially independent in property and
i've done it for years
before i started teaching i've been in
proper town for 12 years but with lease
option agreements the reason it's so
dangerous
to teach it when you've not actually
experienced it properly
not just secure a lease option agreement
but seen it out till the very end of the
contract
because this let's say you agree to buy
a property on a lease option agreement
and you say look
but i'll buy it now i'll take it on now
i'll control it now but i'll pay you in
five years time at the end of the five
years
when you go to buy the property most
mortgage lenders in fact i think just
about all mortgage lenders
will be unhappy when you apply for a
mortgage to buy the house unless you're
buying it cash but
realistically are you going to have the
cash i mean you might have saved up
monthly
and you might have a deposit ready but
you're probably going to want to buy the
property
and you're probably going to want to buy
it with a mortgage at the end of the
term
you actually go to buy it so you've
saved up your deposit
maybe you've saved it up from the
property you apply for a mortgage
but if the lender knows that you have
had a previous interest in that property
which you have because you're probably
going to have registered
a restriction on the title deeds on land
registry so that the owner can't sell
the property anyway
so you're probably going to get declined
a mortgage at the end of the term
because they're going to say no you've
already got a financial interest in this
property therefore makes us uneasy
and we're not going to lend you the
money to buy this property
now you might say why would they do that
though what's the problem don't sign up
for that why class
it is what it is what's the solution
so that's a major pitfall that most
people aren't aware of that do lease
option agreements even people that teach
lease option agreements i'm like
they don't even know this so i have
successfully completed
lease option agreements right to the
bitter end okay many times
and what you do there's a couple of
options option number one
is you buy the and this doesn't this
isn't completely
foolproof but this usually will work
number one is you buy the property at
the end of the seven years
but you buy it in a company so you set
up a company
you call it purple rain limited whatever
you want to call it and then purple rain
limited which is your company
buys the property at the end of the term
now the lender won't be so worried then
because it's not
you buying the property it's the company
buying the property and the company
hasn't had an interest in the property
but you have
now the only potential issue with that
is if the owner refuses to send it to
the company because they say that
you had the contract with them and they
don't want to sell it to purple round
it's rare that'll happen but it could
happen so that's option number one there
is a second option which i have also
done
option number two which is to buy the
property but buy it on a
bridging loan so you're going to put
down your deposit that you've saved
hopefully you've saved it as a result of
the cash flow from that property over
the five years
or however many years you're going to
use that money
and you're going to buy it on a bridging
loan now bridging loans are obviously a
bit risky because they're expensive
you're going to pay maybe one percent a
month
but what you're going to do is you're
going to you're going to buy on a
bridging line you're then going to also
maybe borrow some money or use your own
money to
refurbish the property because chances
are after five years of owning a
property
it's probably going to need a little bit
of a refurb so you're going to change
the carpets you're going to fix it up
and then you're going to refinance the
property but after you've bought it
so that's another option which will
totally get around the problem
so there are pitfalls to lease option
agreements and
it does involve work but there's always
solutions when you know how
so i hope you found this video helpful i
am going to be running a lease option
webinar which is going to be a live
webinar where i'm going to be teaching
through how to find lease option
agreements
how to secure them how to speak to the
seller and explain in such a way
where you can secure properties which is
a remarkable way to buy a property and
it's much better than saving a deposit
so i'll leave in the description i'll
leave the link to that webinar it's
completely free
so i hope to see you there and again
smash the like button if you enjoyed the
video
if you want to know what a lease option
agreement is in the first place and this
video completely confused you then i'd
suggest you check out this video right
here which goes through the basics of
lease option agreements
also if you want to see a video i did
with ian patterson one of my students
who actually built up a very large
portfolio of lease option agreements
which proves that they do work and they
are profitable because he left his
corporate job
check it out right here subscribe check
the videos out
i'll see you next time thanks